SHIGERU MIYAGAWA:
I'm Shigeru Miyagawa.
I'm Professor of linguistics.
And I also teach Japanese
history here at MIT.
This is my 26th year.
My linguistics
work is on syntax.
More recently, I have been
looking at language evolution.
In my history class, I look
at modern Japanese history,
something I started
with John Dower.
He's a very eminent
Pulitzer Prize winning
historian of modern Japan.
John and I have done this
incredible project Visualizing
Cultures, which also
led to the MOOC,
the edX MOOC like that
HarvardX and MITx did together
Visualizing Japan.
Three years ago, I split
my position between MIT
and the University of Tokyo.
And at the University
of Tokyo, I'm
the Director of
Online Education.
And there I look at MOOCs
and also OpenCourseWare.